commence ma journée elle a voulu me
comment dire me
arnaquer me faire une filouterie par
rapport à l'argent que je lui donne 50 €
pour qu'elle aille chercher un billet de
100 départs
tout de suite d'accord
les vidéos que j'aperçois qu'il y a
quelque chose dans la main et je peux
pas dire ce que c'est
peut-être un briquet ou un couteau ou
une seringue
j'ai vu des gens dans la rue d'ouvrir le
carreau et hurler et vous avez hurlé
[Musique]
quand même vous avez été très choqué
parce qu'il s'est passé je suis
franchement je suis traumatisément
peut-être tout le système des VTC à
revoir parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'agressions de chauffeurs de plus en
plus d'agressions de passagers je crois
qu'il y a de moins en moins de
chauffeurs parce que les conditions